in this lesson we're going to explore
the mechanism of fructose bisphosphate
aldolase or aldolase for short
to begin we need to review a few key
organic reactions
the first is iminium ion formation in
this reaction an aldehyde or ketone
reacts with a primary or secondary amine
in this example dimethyl amine typically
in the presence of weak acid to give an
iminium ion the amine attacks this
protonated carbonyl so the carbonyl can
react with some of the acid forming a
bond and then dehydration occurs so
we'll lose water in this reaction and
form the iminium ion the second reaction
we need to review is the aldol
condensation here we have two ketones
and we can react these in the presence
of acid or base under acidic conditions
will form an enol from one of these
reactants and under basic conditions
will form an enolate let's use the base
catalyzed example and show the enolate
that will form this enolate can then
attack the unreacted ketone and
following a protonation step we'll get a
hydroxy ketone these often eliminate
spontaneously or with a little bit of
warming of the solution to give Ino
n--'s this reaction is reversible and
there is a reverse of this reaction
that'll actually go in this direction
cleaving the bond right here and that's
called the retro aldol will begin from
the hydroxy ketone and if we treat this
with base we'll get some deprotonation
of this alcohol the alkoxide that we
make can push these electrons back down
promoting the cleavage of this bond here
the arrow pushing looks like this and if
we follow our arrows will produce an
enol a and a ketone so we're showing
this enolate forming from this bond
breaking in these electrons pushing up
and these electrons pushing back down
give our ketone you're probably less
familiar with the retro aldol then the
aldol
action the aldol reaction is quite
common but the retro aldol is pretty
rare it's actually really hard to cleave
carbon-carbon bonds even forming an
enolate like this but what if we were
somehow able to combine these two
reactions well what would happen
aldolase does just this so let's take a
look if we combine these reactions will
start still from our hydroxy ketone now
imagine we form an iminium ion from this
carbonyl now when we deprotonate this
hydroxyl and i'm gonna abbreviate a base
just using the letter b with some
electrons on it our arrow pushing will
look like this we can deprotonate reform
the carbonyl break this bond and
neutralize a positive charge on nitrogen
instead of producing a negative charge
on oxygen that's much more favorable
this inna mean here can be converted
back to an iminium ion and since this
reaction was reversible we can get back
to a ketone okay getting back to
aldolase let's take a look at the
overall reaction that this enzyme
catalyzes fructose 1 6 bisphosphate is
going to be cleaved into two 3-carbon
compounds dihydroxyacetone phosphate or
dhap and glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate
which we'll call g3p i'm going to
abbreviate the phosphate group
so in our mechanism will abbreviate this
anywhere that the phosphate group is
hanging off of the organic molecule
we'll show this now you may have noticed
that this doesn't look anything like
these hydroxy ketone compounds that
we're talking about doing retro L dolls
this is the closed chain form of
fructose 1 6 bisphosphate the reaction
actually occurs on the open chain form
so if we envision
bass coming in and deprotonating here
these electrons can push in and open the
ring and now with the enzyme stabilizing
the open form of this compound we can
see we have our carbonyl just like we
have here skip this carbon and then one
away we have an OHA
so we can do this type of reaction this
reaction of course occurs within the
active site of an enzyme so I'm
representing that with this pink line
there's actually an active site lysine
residue that's going to be our amine and
is going to react with our ketone here
now I'm going to draw in a couple of
enzyme residues that we're not going to
define but we're going to use to help us
draw our mechanism easily here's a
generic basic amino acid residue that
can accept a proton and over here I'm
adding an amino acid residue that will
act as a proton donor lysine is often
charged but in order to have a pair of
electrons to attack this carbonyl it
needs to be deprotonated so I've just
represented it in that form this basic
enzyme residue is going to take off
another proton and these electrons that
are left behind will attack our carbonyl
so we'll deprotonate lysine as it
attacks we don't want to make five bonds
to carbon so we're going to cleave the
carbonyl and as the carbonyl opens up it
can grab a proton from the proton donor
amino acid residue now we have this
enzyme bound intermediate bound in a
covalent bond the next step is a mininum
ion formation the lone pair on this
nitrogen will push in and we'll show
this Oh H grabbing a proton from a
proton donor on the enzyme on its way
out I've added an a proton donor so the
lone pair on nitrogen is going to form a
double bond the O H group is going to
leave as water grabbing that proton off
of our enzyme
now with our iminium ion formed like we
had up here we can show the retro aldol
step in aldolase it's an aspartate
residue that comes in and deprotonates
here so when i'm not sure of the
residues i use this shorthand for proton
acceptors and proton donors but in this
case we know the actual amino acid so
I'm drawing out its sidechain so in this
reaction up here aspartate is this base
we can show it taking off the proton
these electrons will push in to make a
carbonyl and I'm just going to mark the
bond that Cleaves with this little
dotted line here so the electrons making
that bond will push up and we can
neutralize the positive charge on the
iminium ion first let's draw everything
that's left on the enzyme so when we
cleave this bond we put a double bond
here and that's reflected here we now
have our single bond to nitrogen since
it's got its electrons back and we have
that here and now let's draw what we
form from this piece so the aspartate
took off this proton we formed a double
bond here so this is our our aldehyde
comes from this carbon here and the rest
of these pieces are the same and this
corresponds to glyceraldehyde
3-phosphate
so we've made one of our products and
the other product is still bound to the
enzyme so we need to get it off of there
first I do want to show you that this
has resonance if we push the lone pair
on nitrogen again so that we make a
double bond we can show these electrons
move on to carbon giving us an anion on
that carbon now remember we protonated
this aspartate residue here let's draw
that back in in its protonated form the
protonated sidechain can provide the
proton to react with this anion now we
have an iminium ion just like we had up
here and remember I mentioned that
mininum ions
and reverse forming ketones again and
that's how we're going to form DHAP to
begin that process we now need to add in
a molecule of water here's our water and
I've added in a generic basic amino acid
residue that can accept a proton here so
that these electrons can form a bond now
all that's left to do is form a double
bond here kick off the lysine side chain
so it's available to catalyze another
reaction and we're going to do that
using basic and acidic enzyme residues
again our proton acceptor deprotonates
the O h the carbonyl reforms and the
lysine side chain grabs a proton as it
Cleaves off of our DHAP molecule and our
lysine residue is now free and available
to bond to another molecule of fructose
1 6 bisphosphate promoting this reaction
again and again